at this altitude I can run my hands this
episode is brought to you by ascent
protein the cleanest least processed
protein I've ever consumed and I have
tried just about everything since well
before the 4-hour body I've started my
day with 20 to 30 grams of protein first
thing that has been part of my routine
but I don't always have the time or
necessarily the desire to cook an entire
meal so what to do protein powders can
be a fast way to get this protein need
met but most products are full of crap
they're bleached they've excess sugar
terrible artificial sweeteners or just
straightforward low-grade low quality
protein a scent contains zero artificial
ingredients and the parent company is
actually a cheese manufacturer so they
produce their own native proteins it's
it's really fascinating and I've looked
at their processing it takes or it took
them about five years to develop you can
mix the protein in as little as four
ounces without any clumps or issues of
mix ability whatsoever and they nailed
the taste they tested it for instance
there's the chocolate version two
hundred and eighty two different
versions they put a lot of money in a
lot of time into R&D for this particular
product and they have both way and my
seller casings so if you want to say
improve body composition and recovery
overnight slow release you can take the
micellar casein or in my case whey
protein I would take post-workout for
instance or in the morning so check it
out these guys are really fascinating
visit ascent protein dot-com forward
slash Tim that's a scen TPR ot ein
dot-com ascent like first ascent going
up ascent protein com forward slash Tim
and you will receive 20% off your entire
purchase if you want a very quick xx 30
grams
to start your day or after workout this
is a fantastic option it is arguably the
best that I've found so again check it
out a scent protein calm forward-slash
Tim this episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com
I love WordPress I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com for everything every day
my site Tim not blog is built on it the
websites for my books including tools of
titans tribe of mentors it's all on
wordpress.com and the founder matt
mullenweg when my close friends has
appeared on this show many times
just search matt mullenweg tequila
Ferriss for quite an exciting time
whether you're looking to create a
personal blog a business site or both
you can make a really big impact right
out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good
company it's used by the New Yorker
jay-z Beyonce 5:38 TechCrunch Ted CNN
and time just to name a handful and one
of my friends at Google she'll remain
nameless has told me that wordpress.com
offers the quote best out-of-the-box SEO
imaginable end quote and it's one of the
many reasons that nearly 30% of the
Internet is run on WordPress you do not
need experience or to hire someone
that's perhaps the best part
wordpress.com guide you through the
entire experience they have hundreds of
designs and templates that you can use
and it's easy to get started there's no
need to worry about security upgrades
hosting any of that they offer 24/7
support and they're very very responsive
if you have questions they get right
back to you and this allows you to
create the highest quality with the
least amount of headache and friction so
if you're building a website period when
my friends come to me and ask what I use
what I recommend they use the answer is
wordpress.com so check it out if you
want to get started today learn more
with a 15% discount off any new plan go
to wordpress.com forward slash Tim to
create your website and find the plan
that's right for you to learn more take
a look
wordpress.com forward slash Tim for 15%
off
new website check it out hello ladies
and gentlemen this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show
I am so giddy so excited about this
episode and it is one in a series of
close to 300 episodes now where each
time around I try to deconstruct a
world-class performer and share with you
the stories the habits routines beliefs
negotiating skills in this particular
case that you can test and apply in your
own lives these are the skill sets that
help each of these interviewees become
the best at what they do and our guest
today is none other than the one and
only Sir Richard Branson at Richard
Branson and pretty much everything he's
Richard Branson on Twitter Richard
Branson on Facebook are Branson on
LinkedIn and if you don't know who he is
Richard Branson is the founder and
chairman of the Virgin Group
he is a world-famous entrepreneur
adventurer activist and certainly
business icon he's launched a dozen
billion-dollar businesses and hundreds
of other companies the origins are crazy
the later stories are even crazier and
his new autobiography finding my
virginity and I have a long history with
Richard's books which we get into in
this episode but his new auto buying my
virginity shares the candid details of a
lifetime of triumphs and failures both
of which have been very spectacular and
provides an intimate look at his quest
to push boundaries break rules and seek
new frontiers this episode was recorded
as he was bouncing around the globe and
primarily in Marrakech or Marrakech
depending on how you want to pronounce
it Morocco so the music you hear in the
background his due to that we worked
very hard to get this scheduled I loved
this conversation I've heard a lot of
commerce
with Richard before including in person
I think this one really delivers the
goods we covered a lot and got into a
lot of details talked about many things
I'd never heard him talk about before
including his thoughts on clean meat if
you don't know what that means we'll get
into it blockchain cryptocurrency how
he's coped with dyslexia and how his
parents helped make him resilient the
behind the scenes stories of deal-making
PR stunts big wins and in some cases big
losses the habits and life decisions
he's used to maintain high energy levels
for decades now how he caps her limits
downside risk even though he's perceived
as a risk-taker how and why he takes say
regular one to two months sometimes
longer breaks from alcohol favorite
books lessons learned from Nelson
Mandela and many others and much much
more we cover a ton I was really nervous
about this episode for a host of reasons
and could not be happier with how it
turned out so I hope you enjoy it as
much as I enjoyed it and definitely find
finding my virginity at all
fine booksellers you can check it out
I'm certainly gonna be digging in myself
and with a further adieu please enjoy my
extremely wide-ranging conversation with
Sir Richard Branson
Richard welcome to the show thank you
very much nice to talk to you I have
been looking forward to this
conversation for more than 20 years
[Laughter]
anyway congratulations on all you've
achieved as well thank you no I
appreciate it
we've we've bumped into each other here
and then different points around the
world but I've always wanted to sit down
and very selfishly ask you a lot of
questions ever since I bought your first
autobiography losing my virginity
and have carried it with me since
college through starting all of my
businesses since I thought we could just
begin I suppose with current events I've
been following you around the planet to
have this conversation which I'm
thrilled that we're able to have because
you've gone through some pretty
extenuating circumstances recently could
you describe for us I saw your Instagram
post for instance about retreating into
the wine cellar under your home or the
main building I suppose it was on Necker
Island I where are you right now and
could you describe what that experience
was like it's a strange thing to say but
I reckons before this one and about one
every 10 10 years in the Caribbean and
you know a force one force to hurricane
by and large is magnificent it's you
know it's dramatic to see the sea drops
the the trees Bend the incredible
lightning storms and and it's one of
those sort of marvels of life and you
know yes there's damage you know trees
come down and generally speaking you
know that the damage is you know you
could you can overcome that damage this
hurricane was altogether different and I
mean the you you've got sort of force 5
category post 5 hurricanes as the
highest it goes the hurricane that was
coming to hit us was actually category 7
they didn't even have it in the books
you know I was definitely gonna stay on
an island because we had 60 members was
starvin island but I knew that
it would be foolish to be you know up in
the main house watching nature at its
worst we had to get into a very very
very secure area and so the moment it
started hitting we went down into a
concrete bunker at the bottom of the
house and for five hours I mean it
streamed I mean it was you know the
whole concrete bunkers shuddered and you
know there were young girls as well as
the guys or a couple of children in the
bunker there was a number of Tears water
was pouring through but I don't think
any of us feared for our lives we knew
that we were in a strong area we felt
for 600 flamingos on the lake we felt
for the lemurs that that was still
outside we felt for the people of the
rest of the Caribbean and the British
Virgin Islands who lived in you know
wooden shacks and and buildings that
weren't nothing is strong its strong and
then equally suddenly it stopped I mean
it was suddenly there was a complete
hash outside and we waited 15 minutes
and we couldn't work out whether this
the end of the storm or whether we were
in the eye of the storm and we stuck her
head out of the door and I just looked
at complete utter devastation It was as
if a hurricane had hit hit the island
and you know I don't often cry over
possessions or you know that you know
being damaged but yeah definitely I
think all of us had tears in our eyes
but in five minutes the other side of
the storm hit and we threw ourselves
back in to the hurricane shelter and we
had them there for another four or five
hours and when we finally came out we we
surveyed the damage and you know on our
own Island it was pretty devastating to
say the least
within 24 hours we'd we've started going
around the the rest of the British
Virgin Islands and I mean 90% of homes
were destroyed or nearly destroyed
incredible that more life wasn't lost
and incredible the resilience of the
Caribbean people having stories you know
that be told you know like one person
told me of the house disappearing about
their head with their children their
grandchildren in it running to the
neighbor's house that then disappeared
you know running into a wall the wall
started collapsing and they ended up the
whole family in a cess pit up to their
knees in in [ __ ] and that they survived
it and you know there's a it was a 13
year old girl who within three days was
I had set up a a makeshift school
outside teaching it's younger than her
and so anyway very resilient people and
and you know the last couple month I
just spent trying to work out ways of
seeing whether the whole of the
Caribbean but the whole of the British
Virgin Islands can come back better and
stronger and and you know cleaner and
you know see if we can get some positive
things that come out of what's obviously
been you know the sad event I'd love to
dig into your I suppose we could golf
familiarity with what some people would
look at as near-death experiences I that
this is from a New Yorker profile but
you hold records and the writer observed
you might also hold the record for the
number of highly publicized near-death
experiences so if this was this was a
some time ago I mean this is 10 years
ago 2007 but pulled from the sea five
times by helicopters once from a frozen
lake during one of your attempts to
circle the globe crashed into the
Algerian Desert the Chinese Air Force
threatened to shoot one of your balloons
out of the sky at one point and it goes
it goes on and on when you are in
circumstances like that and you
mentioned you had a lot of staff down in
the in the basement with you what did
you say to those people if there were
people there who were very very worried
or perhaps panicking and some in some
sense what did you say or what did you
do in those circumstances I think humor
is important putting on a brave thing on
a brave face you cracking cracking
cracking jokes
hugs I mean I think hugs are important
you know but I think you know like when
we were all down all down in the bunker
and I mean just to try to reassure them
that you know that even 200 mile an hour
winds were not going to bring us sort of
concrete you know concrete bunker down
you know with some of my other some of
the other adventures where we were you
know in in in a capsule up in me and you
know fly it flying you know flying
around the world and when things went
wrong you know there were just two of us
generally and you know both of you
you've got to try to keep the spirits
that the other the other person up and
if you get a survive the only way you're
going to survive is by keeping focused
by you know staying positive even if you
are pacing almost certain death I mean
it's but you know you're definitely
you're definitely going to die unless
you stay focused and stay positive and
and fight to the bitter end and you know
there have been circumstances where you
know on paper we had a well over ninety
percent chance that I'm not coming home
and and I think by staying focused by
staying positive and and with you know a
big dose of good fortune we made it all
the way back so if we rewind the clock
then I mean these are some of the
exploits that you're known for but if we
rewind the clock back to childhood I'd
read that one of your head masters had
observed or he'd said to you actually I
predict you will either end up in prison
or a millionaire I don't know if that's
true this is you have to be careful what
you read on the internet but if that is
true what what do you think this
headmaster saw in you or observed in you
at such a young age that would that
would lead to such a statement I true it
was his parting words to me as I left
left school just turning 16 and you know
I think that you know I am dyslexic I
was dyslexic so conventional schooling
definitely passed me by
and I was somebody that you know felt
very strongly about some of the issues
in the world the biggest issue in the
world at that time was a very unjust war
the Vietnamese war I mean most wars are
very unjust with yet another very very
unjust war and I like many young people
was determined to try to campaign very
hard to stop the war and and I thought
maybe the best way of doing it was to
launch a magazine for young people that
could be distributed not just among
schools but universities as well which
would be a campaigning magazine and it
would give young people the voice that
they didn't have you know I started
planning this magazine at school and
working out the school phone books
trying to sell advertising and you know
rigging out James Baldwin or John Paul
Sartre or or you know Vanessa Redgrave
or any anybody I felt who you know Terry
Callie and you burn it cohn-bendit from
from Germany anybody I felt that you
know could contribute to a magazine
campaigning magazine like this and and
getting them to contribute and and
surprisingly you know managed to get an
advertising I'm to cover the printing
and the paper costs of the first issue
and so when the headmaster called me in
and said you know you could you either
stay at school and stop doing this
magazine idea of yours and it's
concentrate on your schoolwork or you
can have to leave school to run your
magazine it was an easy decision for me
and and I'm grateful to the headmaster
for being such a foolish headmaster I
mean obviously and I met him a few years
later and and you know he was he was
very gracious and congratulate somehow
success and so on but but I think you
know I did end up in prison for a night
a few years later and I definitely and
that was before I'd become a millionaire
so
I think you know I remembered the
Headmaster's words and I remember how
unpleasant being in prison for a night
is and I'm saying to myself you know I
will never ever ever do anything that
warrants to be going to prison again so
it was it was I think everybody should
spend a night in prison say yeah say
yeah actually got he actually got it
right on on both both counts what did
you do
that led or what happened that led to
that night in prison what happened was
whilst we had the magazine we started in
the magazine a little mail-order company
for people who wanted to buy music and
we called this mail-order company Virgin
Records
nobody had sold music cheaply before so
we you know we discounted it I tend to
tent it 30% off and and we sold music
that we love so you know Frank Zappa
captain B thought brought you know it
was rock and roll music rather than sort
of Andy Williams and the mixture of
rubbish that other rubbish that was out
there and and so the public loved it it
you know it resonated with young people
we had good taste and we were aiming at
kids with good taste and and then one
day somebody ordered some records from
Belgium from us a big a big group a big
large you know amount of Records from
Belgium and so we've you know we got a
lorry and we drove across the rows down
to Dover Dover and across to France and
when we got to France they said where
you take it where you selling these
records and we said in in in Belgium and
they said well you're not allowed to
come through France and sell them in
Belgium without a Carney which means
that you're not going to leave them in
France so you're gonna have to go back
to England and as we were driving back
to England we realized that we had all
these pieces of paper sign that said
that we exported them and now if we
could sell them in England we wouldn't
have to pay the 35 percent tags so
foolishly
we sold them in England and you know
what we didn't realize
that there were other bigger retail
chains doing something very similar in a
much more professional way and there was
a you know a group of Customs and Excise
people who were investigating this this
idea and anyway so we got busted and
fortunately didn't get a criminal record
because you know they said you can act
you can you can pay the fine off over
three years and as long as you pay the
fine off you won't get a criminal record
and and actually it spurred on the
opening of you know we had to open 30 or
40 record stores in order to pay off
Richards fine and even myself out of
prison and so very great very grateful
to Customs and Excise for giving us that
incentive what did your parents say to
you at that time when you got in trouble
and ended up in jail and how old were
you at the time if you could place us I
was 19 years old still 18 they're just
about allowed to be naughty I remember I
was in in Dover Magistrates Court and
the judge said he wanted you know 10,000
pounds bail and and I said look there's
no way I can afford ten thousand pounds
bail and so he said well you know I'm
sorry but you'll have to go to prison
and wait wait and await the trial then
and my mother stood up and said well
what about if I pledged the family home
would you with that but that vo right
and the judge was good enough to you
know say that that would be fine if you
pledged the family house you could be
fine so I gave my mother a very very big
hug and many many years later I mean you
know right right you know fifty years
later nearly you know we're now working
very hard in America to try to help
people who can't afford bail get bail
and you know there's this awful
situation in the states for instance
where you know where if you've got money
or if you've got a house to pledge you
don't go to prison for six months
waiting awaiting your trial but if
you're if you're a poor often black in
you know you end up languishing in
prison for a few months while waiting
for your trial even although you can be
completely innocent so so obviously
obviously lots of personal experiences
come back and
and influence my life later on well I'd
like to talk about influence you
mentioned your mother and in preparing
for this conversation I took a closer
look at your mom and I have to say what
I was going to do is not mention the
last name and read this description but
your mom also wrote a book called moms
of the word the high-flying Adventures
of Eve Branson I just have to read a few
lines here to give people some context a
classically-trained ballet dancer she
appeared in racy West End productions
disguised herself as a boy to take
glider lessons and listed in the women's
Royal Navy service and then embarked on
a series of harrowing adventures as a
star girl air hostess
on the ill-fated British South American
Airways and it goes on and on this seems
to potentially explain a lot and I was I
was curious to know specifically when
you were a kid struggling with dyslexia
and I'm not sure if it was even properly
diagnosed at the time but how did your
your mom respond to that what did she
tell you when you were having trouble
with school or having trouble reading
how did your parents or your mother and
help you navigate that what was the
experience like I have a very
extraordinary mother and we're very very
close-knit family and that's fortunately
continued with myself my wife and
children and so on ever since so so
that's given us a fantastic foundation
as a family when I was young the word
dyslexia I don't think existed I don't
think the word entrepreneur exists
either except maybe in the French
dictionary and so they say it was just
assumed that I was thick and you know
they just got used to you know these
dreadful marks that came back on you
know my maths paper or my English paper
and so on and and and I think that made
it that much easier when I actually said
that I want to leave school you know age
15 I think although that my dad bought
me around the garden three times instead
of
once you know by the end of the walk and
I remember him saying you know look at
least you know what you want to do at 15
I didn't what I wanted to do when I was
22 it I respect you for that
and go give it a go and if it doesn't
work out we'll try to help you get ahead
in a formal education again you know my
mother you know she you know her whole
approach and bringing up her children
was one where she would she would have
been arrested today in those days she
could get away with it so you know you
know at age four or five she would you
know shove me out of the car you know
two or three miles from grandmother's
house and tell me to make my own way
there she would you know put me on a
bicycle aged seven or eight and tell me
to write you know 300 miles in the
pouring rain again to cram about the
size and her attitude was you know if we
survived you know would be the stronger
porridge she wouldn't allow us to watch
television for instance we had to get
out there and do things and then and you
know so she would push this attitude out
of the house and you know tell us to
come back in the evening and and you
know get out there gun client please
rescue cats you know and see you tonight
so you know we lived in the countryside
and you know it was a you know it was it
was a fun fun upbringing and very very
loving upbringing and it may not sound
like it she wasn't actually trying to
kill us as well what what would she say
to you one for instance it's raining out
you're in the car would she give you any
warning and what would she say to you if
if it was raining and she wanted you to
get out and ride a bike home in the
pouring rain
was there any any kind of lead up and
he's any lesson that she would impart
before that I'm just thinking I don't
have any kids myself but I think about
parenting a lot what what can you replay
for us just one of those scenes so we we
know how is presented to you I think
that getting out of the pushing us out
of the car was most likely I was most
likely having a debate with my younger
sister and and and say it wasn't really
yeah this is this is going to be a life
lesson it was more
chubbie [ __ ] shove it shoving the
brakes on pushing us out of the car
slamming the door and driving off this
house yeah we as I say we did survive
and I mean I I remember distinctly when
I was five on that about that very
occasion walking across the field and I
was young enough to decide I wanted to
get my own back on her and and I saw a
farmhouse and I walked very slowly
towards the farmhouse and so I wasn't
too worried because I could see the
lights of the farmhouse but I was damned
if I was going to do it quickly
because I thought she's gonna she's
gonna have to suffer this time and she
did suffer and I don't think she as
readily pushed me out of the car anyway
it's fun I mean I just you know mums
1994 now and I just I just saw her a few
minutes ago and she will never stop I
mean she's got an idea a minute and you
know we've always had to run to keep up
with her and you know put the two of us
together it's a dangerous context so I I
think that many people have the
impression of you as a fly by the seat
of the pants
entrepreneur who throws caution to the
wind and bets the farm on many many
things and what I'd love to talk about
is maybe the the alternative to that or
the compliment to that we don't have to
do either/or which is risk mitigation
because the the more I look at what
you've done in many cases not all cases
but in many cases you seem like a master
at mitigating risk and capping the
downside so I was hoping maybe you could
talk about I believe it was I think you
are enroute if you could clarify for me
to be bi and there was a flight canceled
in Puerto Rico but how you actually
ended up in the airline business because
I find it's such an illustrative and
helpful story if you wouldn't mind
telling people a little bit about the
origins
I was in my 20s I'd been away from my
girlfriend for three weeks I was coming
back to see her that night I was in
Puerto Rico about 6:00 and evening I was
heading to the Virgin Islands and
American Airlines announced that they
were going to move the flight the next
morning because they didn't have enough
passengers and I was damned if I was
gonna wait to the next one I new
girlfriend hadn't seen me for three
weeks and I haven't seen her for three
weeks so I was determined to get there
that night
so I went to the back of the airport
hoping that my credit card wouldn't
bounce I I rented a plane I'd borrowed a
blackboard and as a joke I wrote Virgin
Airlines one-way $29 or $39 to the
British Virgin Islands and I went out
amongst all the people who'd be in bunt
and I killed that my first plane and as
we arrived in the EBI 9/11 I'd one of
the passengers you know tapped me on the
shoulder and said you know sharpen up
the service a bit Richard and you could
be in the airline business so that it
got me thinking you know Airlines do
bump people you know most airlines you
don't look after people you know that
will start generally don't smell the
food was dreadful I mean and so the next
morning I was on Necker Island and and I
rang up throwing and I asked to talk to
the sales department and a wonderful man
who I got to learn know very well of
years called the r.j. Wilson answer the
phone and the call went roughly like
this they're done mate you know my name
is Richard Branson and I'm interested in
buying a secondhand seven four seven and
our Jay Wilson said well you know would
you mind telling me you know what you do
I said I'm in the record business I've
got the Rolling Stones I've got the sex
with I've got Janet Jackson and lots of
wonderful artists and I could sort of
feel that he was you know like feeling
that I was slightly wasting his time and
he said and you're basing and I said
well our company's based in England and
so he carried on talking but and
subsequently I learned that he carried
on talking because they were so fed up
with British Airways always legging
legging it's over them because they had
no competition and they thought in the
back of his head in mind he was thinking
maybe that by having a competitor to
British Airways they'd be able to have a
bit more leverage so so he said look
I'll tell you what I'll come and see you
you know we do happen to have one
secondhand 707 but for the name like
I've really feel you should change the
name with the name like virgin people
will think you're not going to go the
whole way I I said well thank you for
your advice and I think I think about
that so I then talk to my fellow record
company team and and they went into
complete panic mode I mean you know
wasn't Richard doing thinking of taking
us into the airline business we have the
most successful independent record label
in the world where you know we just
signed the Rolling Stones we've got you
know everything's going from strength to
strength and then you know he's putting
everything's going to put everything at
risk by going to the airline business
and so what I said to them was look I
promised that you know I'll only go into
the airline business on one condition
and that is if I can persuade Boeing to
let me hand the plane back at the end of
the first year I need to protect the
downside so I knew that the worst that
could happen with the you know maybe six
months of the profits of Virgin Records
we would lose so we didn't work out and
Boeing agreed and you know when the end
of the first year came instead of
handing the plane back people loved
Virgin Atlantic and you know we had a
you know you know people flock to it and
we had a spirit about it which is very
different from British Airways we ended
up buying a couple bought some
secondhand 747s from Boeing and and then
you know over the years since we bought
some hundreds of planes from you know
prepare the three or four different
airlines you set up over the years from
Boeing so Jay Wilson certainly deserves
and pat on the back of going I think how
did you convince
rjb to agree to allow you to return the
plane if things didn't work out
what was the what was the pitch or what
was the was the approach well we liked
each other which it was I think it's
always important in in any negotiation
and you know he admitted that you know
one of the reasons they wanted to see us
in business was to you know to enable
them to have a little bit of competition
with British Airways and you know I
think and you know you know I think we
showed him that we managed to build a
very successful global record company
and you know unlike other people I mean
you know I argued that being an entity
you know being an entertainment actually
you know that's important there in the
airline business that most airline
owners just just you know see Airlines
as a way of transporting people from A
to B and that actually entertaining
people is important and if people are
locked in a tin can for eight or nine
hours or 12 hours they want to be
entertained and that you know that I
felt we could bring our entertainment
skills to that you know when British
Airways heard that we were going to go
into the business they dismissively said
all King famously said too young to fly
too old to rock-and-roll and followed up
by saying you know what earth is
somebody from the entertainment business
going to be a long distance but of
course that's just what British Airways
didn't realize was they were not you
know they were they were dumping a bit a
lump of chicken on somebody's laughs
they were showing you know maybe one
film and people were lucky on the screen
two children two grannies to business
people you think there was no choice
there was you know they had cabin crew
who weren't given the tools to do a good
job and therefore they never smiled and
and so it went on and so you know
exactly what the airline industry what
needed was an airline that could
entertain people you know so we when we
launched Virgin Atlantic with our one
plane you know we had stand-up bars we
had you know we had cabin crew were
absolutely delight you're delightful and
you loved what they were doing
we had humor I mean we'd show the film
an aeroplane on the first flight you
know when we're in the cockpit we
had you know we should we told our
passengers that they were going to see
the the pilots and you know the screen
came on and there was the backs of the
heads of the pilots and okay it became
became apparent they had quite long hair
and and then you know two famous
cricketers turned around and handed each
other a split they were they the front
pilots and then I took the spoke I was
the pilot just behind them and and it
was deathly harsh in the plane and just
as we took off and and and then I stood
up so they could see I wasn't actually
in the cockpit and pretty pre
pre-recorded about the day before and
the whole plane the whole plane just
fell about laughing and yeah the journey
the journey over the more champagne was
drunk I think that on any any flights
before or after and you know the pilot
you know he would you know he got into
the sense of humor so you know he'd be
flying along and he'll agley you'd have
the plane slightly leaning to the right
and and and then he would ask all the
passengers on the right-hand side of the
plane sorry look it's just too many
people partying on the right with some
of you move over to the left please and
then he would it was a laugh a minute
the whole way but for anybody who's
thinking my god I would never fly on
this man's airline you know we we've got
I got the chief technical officer
British Caledonian to actually run our
airline you know obviously safety is
paramount you're running an airline and
thirty-five years later you know we have
many airlines and it's been they've all
been wonderfully run but that doesn't
preclude you entertaining people that
doesn't preclude humor that doesn't
preclude you know we're always trying to
be cutting-edge you know whether it's
seat back videos we you know we push the
industry to invent a seat back video and
we worked ID before British Airways
whose feedback videos giving people a
choice and you know so we love trying to
you know cut through and do things
differently and you know from others and
and I think that's why
Virgin Atlantic has survived before
their airlines have done well I mean
when you know we're not when we set up
with one plane we were competing with TW
way with Pan Am with air Florida with
Laker Airways with people this press and
so on with handle all of these they're
most of these airlines with hundreds of
planes and we had one claim and the the
graveyard of airlines was massive I mean
like people who tried to go into the
island business and failed and over the
next three or four years pretty well all
these airlines including a lot of others
there your ab dan air all went bankrupt
you know and somehow is this little
David versus these goliaths survived you
know because you know because we offered
it at a product and and British Airways
did not like it I mean they they were
absolutely determined to drive us out of
business and and as they had driven out
business a lot of these other airlines
and they launched something called the
dirty tricks campaign I mean it wasn't
publicly known as the dirty tricks
campaign in the early days because
nobody knew it was going on but they
they set up but I in closed doors group
of people who tapped our computer
information and they would ring our
passengers they would pretend for
instance to be from Virgin and then say
very sorry your plight is being delayed
but we can move you onto a British
Airways flight or and people going into
the nightclubs that we owned in London
we had a big gay nightclub called heaven
and then all through the rustle through
the e the bins outside and try to find
easels or anything that would look like
the MonaVie drugs would be taken in the
club and then they would you know the
stories to the news of the world dots
papers and try to damage us that way all
they would have people getting through
my own rubbish bins which they got
caught doing and journalists rubbish
bins that we maybe and talk to and they
would try to spread stories about our
finances and in the end we decided to
take them to court and it was
Christmastime and we won the biggest
libel damages in history against British
Airways and and we distributed it to all
our staff equally and because it was
Christmastime
it
came down as the British Airways
Christmas bonus and I think us I'll
start by hoping that British Airways
will get up to their tricks the game but
I mean I mean you know that helped help
so anyway keep them keep them on a
slightly more honest as the time went on
how did you identify the dirty tricks
campaign had it how did it become
discovered it was generally speaking
British Airways staff that came to us I
mean particularly one one particular
individual who actually worked in the
lot behind the locked doors tapping our
computer information who felt very
uncomfortable about it you know and and
others I mean you know for instance they
were they were they had a teams of
people in New York who were going up to
our passengers I got out of their
limousines to board a virgin plane again
saying I'm sorry that the virgin plane
has been the label has a problem but I'd
be sent here by virgin to take over the
British Airways and some of our
passengers managed to rumble them on
this one and and and let us know so you
know say it was a combination of
different things and there was one
person was just caught red-handed
again going through the rubbish bins
yeah so we were like lucky to get it
exposed I mean you know one of the sad
outcomes of this was they were they were
they were also dumping capacity on on
the few routes that we had and that's a
that's the normal trick of it you know
big airlines against small airlines they
can afford to lose man on a few routes
to drive and competitor out of business
and then they'll Jack the prices up once
that competitors out of business you
know and it was beginning to cost us and
so so I had to make it a difficult
decision we had the you know the most
successful independent record label in
the world by the and you know I knew
that the only way of being completely
sure qpl I'm going and saving all the
jobs that the record company was to sell
one of the other another the airline we
could never sell so we talked to thorn
EMI and and they bought they bought the
little company and you know this billion
dollars and so
you know it should have been happy day
but actually it was one of the saddest
days my life was selling a company is
selling in full we built this company up
from scratch it has been tremendous fun
building Virgin Records but you know we
now had the cloud part to be sure that
the the start of the record company's
jobs was secure but you know under
different ownership and Andy airline
secure and with that billion dollars we
knew that British Airways would have to
think twice before you know they want
the most out he would realize that we
were we were here to stay
thank you for that explanation and
context because it gives me a number of
jumping-off points the first being I
suppose opportunity and in risk
assessment so you strike me as a really
good negotiator by by necessity you'd
have to be if you had say it would be
entrepreneur or a university senior
someone who's about to graduate and go
into the real world
and you wanted they tell you that they
want to become a very good negotiator a
very good deal maker
how would you train them or what would
you recommend they do or read to become
a better negotiator or deal maker
because you seem very very astute and
subtle and structuring things in in very
smart ways what would you say to someone
who wants to develop that skill set I'm
sure there must be ways that being
taught it but in my opinion nothing
beats them beats you know personal
experience and my education was you know
being turned into the jungle being
thrown into the real world age 15 or 16
and been to survive and it was an
incredible education and you know I
learnt about everything in life you know
you know traveled a lot I'd met met
people all over the world I you know I
had to do a lot of different variations
you know I think as I've got older I've
realized the the one of the most
important things about a negotiation is
striking a deal that is fair to both
sides I also realized as I get older
that you're always come across
the same people time and time again in
life and so your reputation is
everything you know in my new book
branding opportunity I talked about our
dealings with Delta and how you know the
print they felt that bade leg diss over
an in a clause in a contract and how
they they came to us to rectify it and
you know this that's something I'll
never forget in and most likely will be
you know pardon some delta for the rest
of my life because of that you know that
you know that kind of that kind of
approach and you know so I think you
know if you if you realize that your
reputation is all you have and your
personal reputation the reputation of
your brand then you've got to make sure
that you're you're you're negotiating a
deal that that you're not going to be
unhappy with and that and you think of
all the things could potentially go
wrong and how you can get out of it if
some pairs wrong but equally important
is you know is strike two trying to
strike a fair balance with the people
you're negotiating with and when when
we're looking internally you mentioned
how your teammates at the record company
thought you were crazy when you brought
up the airline are there any business
ideas that you're glad your coworkers or
team have prevented you from doing as
you know my nickname is doctor yes and
you know I I have books like screw it
just do it and I think it'd be honest
that I want to do something one of the
advantages of owning the company is I
can normally ultimately get away with it
I mean I'll try obviously to carrot
carry people to me but and I I'm sure
they've been one or two things which I
where I have fully believe the process
true where I've regretted not regretted
I've never regretted anything but where
perhaps I should have listened more to
others but and I can't think of anything
that work you know where they persuaded
me not to do it I think most likely you
know when it comes to a decision about
whether to do something or not I'm gonna
like to think of myself as a benevolent
dictator
that's the one there's the one thing I
sort of generally get my own way on we
look we would never have gone into space
travel will come to that I'm sure later
on in this talk you know unless I was
to do to do things against the against
the sensible you know what would you
know on paper these sensible advice that
my fellow directors we will definitely
get the space travel what I'm curious
about because it seems if I look at many
of the businesses that you've started
the positioning is often against a
particular incumbent in the case of say
Airlines for instance that seems to be a
common element in a lot of the company
or product launches and I want to
connect that with just some of your
well-known adventures and you'll see
where this is going in a second I mean
you've driven a tank down Fifth Avenue
across the English Channel in an
amphibious car took a four hundred and
seven foot jump off the Palms Casino
Resort in Las Vegas I've gone from
Morocco to Hawaii and a hot air balloon
you you are very very adept at PR stunts
getting attention for the things that
you do in the companies that you do it
is are there any particular best
practices or a playbook that you have
found to be very or principles for that
matter helpful with the launching of a a
new company or product thinks that I
mean I'm a great believer in buying if
your team worked really hard to to
launch a new business with you or for
you the least i think i can do is is
make a fool of myself make sure that
that new business ends up on the front
page of the newspapers rather than an
anecdote on the pages of newspapers so
if that means having to use myself to
put the new company on the map I will do
so and I will try to do it in a way that
makes a little smile and that that
doesn't horribly backfire on me aside
additionally it has back bad you know
and I suppose it's like being a host to
a party I mean if you're the host of the
party if you stand in the corner of the
room and you sip your sherry and stand
around with your fellow directors all in
suits everyone's going to have a
thoroughly dull party and ya know
nobody'll have a good time if you're you
know the host of the party and you're
first in the swing pool and and
everybody else jump into
yeah they may be a bit cold for the rest
the evening but yeah they're going to
have a great evening and I think the
same applies when you're launching your
business you know make sure that you put
it on the map and then and just
occasionally it will it will backfire
you mentioned space travel which I do
want to use as a touching off point to
ask you roughly 50 years after starting
your first business why why right
finding my virginity what was the the
catalyst for that why do it
I actually think every everybody should
write a book about their lives I
persuaded a number of people to write
books about their lives keeps the faucet
for instance and even a number of people
but it you know you don't have to let a
very public life
I think everyone's led interesting lives
your children and your grandchildren you
know will be fascinated by the lives the
lives you lead and so I wrote a book on
losing my virginity when I was a young
man a battle all the adventures you know
it became a best-seller and and sold
millions of copies but you know I was I
was quite a young man when I wrote it
and the last 20 years or so I've had
been very full and very rich and you
know extraordinary so so I thought I
would write and in a sense a sequel to
losing my opportunity with you which we
call finding my virginity and and if I
live another 20 years a virginity found
I suspect cooking my last book but we'll
see how we go but no but I think you
know I think it's important I loved
reading reading and learning and I think
other others might enjoy hope you enjoy
it and you know when I write books I try
to I try not to make them like her you
know and and then and then we did this
and then we did that just try to make it
a really good gripping read and and an
enjoyable read and and not try to sort
of Crimea and everything one's done in
20 years but and hopefully people can
get a few gems from it as well I'm
looking forward to reading it certainly
made given how dog-eared and how
warned my paperback copy of finding my
virginity is I losing my virginity yes
I'm sorry that's I need more cough I
just had some queer take a little light
on the octan I know exactly where it is
it's actually kept on a bookshelf this
is just a slight digression but there
are a handful of autobiographies and
biographies that have had a large impact
on my life
end or that I find very beautiful in
many ways and they are lined up on one
shelf in my house that I can see the
spines and yours is there opened by
Andre Agassi is there and there are a
handful of others so it's very
meaningful so I'm looking forward to to
reading this and as a meta question what
are the practices if there are any
practices or habits or or anything for
that matter that helps you to keep your
energy level as high as it is over so
over so many years I've I've seen you
for instance you seem to exercise a lot
I've seen you just go for hours an hour
skiing swimming around Necker kite
boarding but could you speak to what
helps you to maintain such a high level
of energy and output over so long it's
it's it's really mind-boggling to me to
even observe from afar looking after
yourself is it's obviously absolutely
key to everything else and everything
everything stems from you know how
healthy and well you are both you know
physically mentally and and so on I
generally do it through sport I've been
very lucky that for many years I've
lived on an island and so I can get up
early in the morning I'll play a very
hard game of singles tennis against
somebody who's better than me I'll then
go kite surfing make maybe go surfing
and then have breakfast and and the day
begins and I'll repeat that no slightly
later on in the day and you know maybe
swim around the island as well so
generally I think I stay healthy and fit
as a family you know my kids are now
taking my adventurous streak
on board so every year they set us a
challenge which we do together so just
to give you a taste of it last year they
set the challenge that we would start at
the matterhorn in Switzerland we're
doing a day hike across the mountains we
then get on a bicycle we drive we would
ride a hundred miles a day on the bike
through the mountains all the way from
the north of Italy to the stubbornest
tip of Italy then we'd swim to Sicily
then we would do another bike ride a
marathon and then we'd end up the top of
Mount Etna it took us a month you know I
was shattered about halfway through it
but by the end of it I felt like a 25
year old and I just never felt so fit
you know since I was in my twenties and
and obviously you know we'll try to
raise money for good cause at the same
time but the very fact that you know we
set ourselves chatting to you something
like tomorrow I'm now in Morocco today
and you know tomorrow where we're about
to climb Mount to coach is the highest
mountain in North Africa together and
and a few other little things like bike
rides and hikes and things thrown in you
know setting ourselves challenges doing
it together as a family
involving friends and and trying to
raise money for good causes you know
that keeps you fit and healthy and your
mind your mind good so that you can and
do a lot more as a result so speaking of
doing good which you can certainly do
through nonprofits and through
for-profits and other vehicles many of
my listeners wanted me to ask you to
expand on your reasons for investing in
Memphis meats and clean meat and so
looking forward to your next 20 years of
adventures could you talk about that
that decision I mean if you take this
beautiful world we live in you know one
of the things that make it so beautiful
is things like the rain the rain forests
and the rain forests are rapidly
disappearing because of our demand for
for beef basically you know for every
every hamburger we eat the amount of
land that is needed to produce it is
considerable and as we're more and more
successful at bringing more and more
people out of poverty on a global basis
more and more people are starting to eat
meats so the only way of addressing this
problem is either to persuade people not
to eat meat which is I don't think it's
going to be you know something something
that we can be successful at all coming
up with alternative forms of meat so you
know there's a wonderful company I think
called beyond meat which produces
hamburgers that tastes absolutely like
hamburgers but are made of made of
vegetables you know there's the other
company you just mentioned that we
progressed it in that is literally you
know growing you're taking a little tiny
little bit of a live animal without
killing it and then growing it in
laboratories so you know so you can have
you know you can have beef or you can
you know have chicken or pig or even
even even fish they believe they'll be
able to do and you can make it even
healthier then the beef or the meat that
you get from from live animals so the
challenge obviously is producing it in
quantity they believe they will be able
to do that and if they can do it
hopefully one day we won't have to cut
down the rainforests and there could
kill kill animals in order to get our
meat consumption and and I suspect you
know when when when that happens we'll
actually look back at the wholesale
slaughter of animals in a way that we
did it and he's slightly embarrassed
about it my main reason for this is more
to do with trying to protect what's left
of our beautiful and if you're looking
at other areas of interest I mean living
as I did for a long time 17 years in
Silicon Valley the the question of this
protein paradox or protein challenge is
a very big one so some people are
looking at insect protein like you
mentioned some people are growing meat
in laboratories others are looking at
vegetable options
another really active area of discussion
is cryptocurrency or blockchain and/or
blockchain
how do you think about if you do
cryptocurrency I mean when you're
hearing all the news and so on are you
engaging with that at all are you using
to step back how are you thinking about
cryptocurrency on this I found
blockchain very exciting I think the
fact that you know Hernando DeSoto has
written some wonderful books about how
do you pull people out of poverty and
you know he say taken Egypt as an
example the 90% of people who live in
Egypt live in houses but they built
those houses just on public land and
they have no piece of paper showing that
they own that land so if they want to
start a business they can't mortgage
their home you know or you know to start
a business they can't use their asset to
borrow money to send their children to
school and so blockchain for instance
would be the perfect place you could go
and register you know the millions or
billions of homes around the world that
have no ownership on blockchain and you
know it can all be in one place and I
and I think it could it could start a
revolution of you know wealth among
support for very poor people you know
cryptocurrency it's not something that
I've spent a lot of time on but I think
i margall had a Bitcoin and the genius
of the man who invented it and you know
what it's achieved so far and you know
and what he could possibly achieve in
the years to come and in a theory amend
some of these other cryptocurrencies
that are coming up again you know hats
off to these geniuses who you know who
are producing and then you know but more
of my energy to be honest is now spent
on you know on different kinds of issues
but I mean if Assin eight about
everything in life and this is one of
those fascinating areas I want to be
respectful of your time I know we don't
have a whole lot left so I'd love to
just ask a few of the audience favorite
rapid-fire questions and then I know
you're bouncing from point to point
right now around the world so I'll let
you get going but the the first question
is
what is the book or books you've given
most as a gift and why outside outside
of your own books are there any
particular books that you've given or
recommended to others the most well
climate change is something which I've
spent a lot of time on I would highly
recommend a book by Tim Flannery called
the weather makers which was one of the
books that opened my eyes to the
problems that we have in the world I'm
just reading home idea switch which I
find is and I will carry on to reach
sapiens is his first book or one of his
first books and I just loved love you
know love this style of his writing and
and you know I love books where you're
learning you're learning something from
them and rather than okay if I want to
if I want fiction I'll get a good film
out and so if I'm if I'm reading books I
like to read books which have got some
substance I love autobiographies or
biographies as well
do you read most of your books to text
or do you listen to audiobooks I'm just
thinking back to the challenges you had
with dyslexia as a younger person have
you learned to cope with those and now
read mostly text or is audio something
that you use much I have largely coped
with these things now and enjoy you know
a good solid book with book
I'm just waiting I'm just doing my own
audio book for finding my virginity it
take takes a long time to take something
long time yeah yeah and so anyway I know
that more and more people do to enjoy
audiobooks and I'm sure it's worthwhile
in the last let's just call it five
years or so what new belief behavior or
habit has most improved your life or it
what what habit has improved your life
could be any new belief behavior or
habit that has markedly improved your
life if we could go back a bit five
years I think oh yeah we can't no we can
go back we can go back as far as you
like absolutely I know that one of the
best things my parents taught me and
going back a long way if I ever said
anything about anybody
they would sit me in front of the mirror
and for ten minutes and in order to sort
of let me know how badly it reflected on
me so you know like to think I've never
gently I've generally never spoken ill
about other people and I think that's
been one of the one of the you know best
bits of advice that I've ever given
sorry I've ever received or and
obviously then given Archbishop Tutu who
chaired the elders which was an
organization that we've run for for ten
years now you know he was the epitome of
forgiveness with the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission in South
Africa when Nelson Mandela you know took
over power and you know I think just
their people nations you know it should
try it we should all try to run based on
that philosophy and I think the world
would be a happier place if that if that
happened you you mentioned Nelson
Mandela this is clearly not one of my
stock rapid for our questions but I've
heard you refer to Nelson as a mentor
are there any key lessons or takeaways
or memorable sentences or anything that
come to mind when you think of your
interactions with Nelson Mandela very
well yes even to the extent that on July
the 18th we shared a birthday and he
would ring me every single birthday to
wish me a happy birthday and you know I
remember yeah the sadness when I didn't
get that call not so many years ago
you know he had an absolute joy for life
and you know he would dance he would
smile he would embrace everybody but he
had a tough sight in as well and I
remember one lunch I had with him early
on in our relationship where you know
I've been warned that he was always
trying to extract money for a good cause
is so you know we had the first course
then we had the second course then we
had the pudding and we were onto the
coffee and I thought my god I'd put away
with it and and then and then he turns
to me and says
last week I had lunch with Bill Gates
and he gave me fifty million dollars for
such-and-such recourse and anyway so he
did not miss an opportunity yeah yeah
many that I have no apart from maybe
Archbishop Tutu I've really never met
and that haven't met anybody as
extraordinary in my lifetime you see
when you yourself feel and maybe you
don't feel this but I'll assume for the
moment that you do when you've felt
overwhelmed or an unfocused or if you
feel like you've temporarily lost your
focus what do you do or what have you
found to help you know what questions do
you ask yourself is there in in those
cases what have you done historically
that is that has been helpful you know I
personally believe that the majority of
people who have down moments in their
lives they can they can actually trace
it back quite often to alcohol you know
so perhaps the only days of my life that
I feel lethargic is you know if instead
of having you know two glasses at
nighttime I had five or six and if I
find that's happened you know on more
than one or two occasions I then give up
completely for you know a month or two
and and feel absolutely fantastic of
course and realize that I'm never going
to drink another touch of alcohol again
until actually you do and and you know
fortunately I yeah I'm so busy that I
that I just can't afford to let myself
down
too often but my guess is that the vast
majority of people you know if you can
if you can be high on life and base and
healthy and and you know if you do find
that there's something like alcohol is
is is just beginning to trip you get go
bit too far you know being high in life
it's just so wonderful Campinas that for
a friend of mine entrepreneur named Matt
Mullenweg he's been on this podcast as
well he's the CEO of a company called
automatic' which is behind wordpress
which powers around 37% of the inner
right now and he told me at one point
that he had learned something along ago
which was alcohol is borrowing happiness
from tomorrow and certainly seems to be
the case I think that there's beautiful
words and they're very very very true
words you know I mean my son's just had
a year and you know look you can tell
he's just so high on life he's just
enjoying enjoying it like like he's
never enjoyed it before and you know so
like if you could do it in moderation
that's great you know I tell the story
in the book there was one one night in
when we in when we won the Grand Prix in
Melbourne and anyway I let my hair down
to such an extent that it would have
made the film hanger would look like a
children's children's film and the next
day I woke up and anyway I get a gate I
gave up for six months and and so yeah
it doesn't happen to me too often but
but I think you know generally it's yeah
generally when that's the one area that
I think a lot of a lot of people who do
you know run into problems their lives
it's slightly too much during those
periods when you go off of alcohol do
you avoid circumstances where other
people are drinking or is there
something that you say to people if you
are in those circumstances how do you
ensure that you don't have just that one
drink that then triggers more drinks if
you're trying to take time away from
alcohol my trick is simply to have
cranberry and soda in a champagne glass
[Laughter]
you know I just remember the champagne
glass then but I think look I think for
a lot of people you especially when
people first give up anything like that
drugs alcohol they need to walk away
completely for a while
fortunately you know I haven't gotten
you know never let myself get to that's
that that's fate but you know but I
think that you know the best advice is
to you know you know just you know
say I need to go to bed early tonight
them and walk away and otherwise it's
very difficult they stick with it
I use now use somebody who drinks or not
or not I don't drink a whole lot I do
enjoy wine fortunately I don't feel like
I've had any issues with alcohol
although genetically my family seems to
have that predisposition I certainly
have a fair amount of alcoholism and my
extended family so I do I think about it
quite a bit I I can I can tell that I
think I have the potential to abuse it
but I haven't up to this point I think
that you and that you and I have such
fascinating lives that you know about
that that is the best way of keeping you
know keeping these sorts of things in
check you know we just we want it we
every day is so interesting that it's
not gonna want to waste waste today
right you know letting something like
that take over your life right no
definitely and just just two more
questions for me this is one really
intended just to give people a window
into how you cope with some of the
harder times do you have a favorite
failure of yours and what I mean by that
is how has a failure or an apparent
failure set you up for later success are
there any particular examples that come
to mind yeah I mean I think on me and on
the adventure side and the first time we
cross the Atlantic and boat we were
trying to break the record for the
fastest crossing of the Atlantic and
getting the blue ribbon back and you
know and we sank and then the next day
we built a new another boat and we were
successful and the British people love
people who are underdogs and and it
taught me that actually in failing and
bending successful most likely was
better than just going out there and
being successful the first time around I
mean the overcoming difficulties the
public almost preferred than someone
who's just successful the first time
around maybe maybe not so much in
America but in person anyway as those
the most notable business failure that
we've ever had was taking on coca-cola
with virgin Cola
and for a while it really looked like we
were going to topple Coke and Pepsi and
we were out selling them in the UK the
Virgin brand resonated people loved the
drink I mean and then you know we landed
in Times Square with thee with a Sherman
tank and you know we took on Coke in
their homeland in America and coke
decided to far back and they filled up
DC tens full of money and hit men and
hit women and they landed in the
territories that we had launched and
they suddenly virgin Cola started
disappearing from all these shells and I
think the lesson I learned from that was
you know if I'm going to take on Aglaia
I've got to be got to be different we've
got to be much better than they are
and you know with a cola you're just
another Cola you're not you can't be
fundamentally different you can be
cheaper but you can't be fundamentally
different so anything we've launched
since then we've only launched new
businesses if we can make a fundamental
difference I love it you know that's so
so important to underscore I think this
is the last rapid-fire question if you
if you could have a giant billboard
anywhere with anything on it so and this
is metaphorically speaking so getting a
message out to millions or billions of
people what would it say and why it
could be a few words could be a
paragraph could be a quote you live your
life by yours or someone else's it does
anything come to mind if you could get a
message out to billions of people what
would you what what might you put on
that billboard I think I going to sound
like a model on stage instead go back to
be a businessman which is you know I
think just something like nothing
ventured nothing gained I think I think
that in life if people you know if
people you know try things and I stick
their neck out they're gonna have a lot
more fun than that if they sit at home
watching other people do it and so yeah
so I think that I don't quote nothing
but just nothing been gained is
important having said that you know I
you know I've been involved for ten
years now in this wonderful group called
the elders and uh Nelson Mandela
set it up and it's now run by Kofi Annan
and I really do believe that in our
lifetime I've seen so many unnecessary
Wars have seen the Vietnamese war I've
seen the Iraq war the Libyan war and
these were all incredibly unjust wars
which have you know gone on to spawn
awful things like Isis and so on which
would not have happened if it wasn't for
actually the West taking it upon
themselves to interfere in other
countries business and killing and
maiming thousands of people and you know
we must make sure that we don't have any
wars in the future and I think it takes
business people it takes society it
takes all of us to really make sure that
our politicians never never take us down
that path again I mean one of the
saddest things I think about the
invasion of Iraq was you know yes there
were thousands of people on the streets
there should have been hundreds and
hundreds of thousands just like the
Vietnamese war to to stop such a foolish
excursion you know all all conflicts
should be able to be resolved by
negotiation and you know even if you
don't get exactly what you want out of
it and that is better than better than
that then all the bloodshed that flows
through from conflict I I think that's a
perfect place to wrap up because it ties
in so much I think that for people
listening whether you want to leave your
mark on the world as a businessperson as
a philanthropist there's actually a very
common skill set when you look at the
highest levels you need to be able to
negotiate you need to know how to deal
make and you're talking about say
ventures and nothing ventured nothing
gained which also ties nicely into add
venture if people look at the etymology
I mean these are very closely related
concepts and I'm just so thrilled that
we were able to find the time to jump on
the phone Richard and have this
conversation
and certainly recommend because I will
be reading it along with everyone else
the people take a look at finding my
virginity I can't wait to pick up where
I left off in Hindi previous installment
is there anything that anything else you
would like to recommend to everyone
listening to the millions of people
hearing this that they do or try ask
themselves any anything at all any next
action or anything else that you'd like
to to leave with as parting words and
would like would obviously look forward
looking forward to seeing you again soon
I was just thinking on we were talking
about alcohol I mean now I think the I
think the converse is true I mean and
and what we were talking about an
alcohol and and that is that I mean if
you say take them take the war on drugs
and there's been going on now for 50
years
as a businessman I would have closed
down the war on drugs 49 years ago I
mean it's been an abject failure and
anti-gay governments have continued to
to perpetuate this war on drugs which
has resulted in you know hundreds of
thousands of people being put in prison
hundreds of thousands of casualties it's
resulted in you know 390 billion the
year going to be under the world and yet
there is that there is a simple answer
and that is if you treat drugs as a
health problem not a criminal problem
and you help people with drug problems
countries that do that are getting on
top of it so you know as and we as a
business leaders are trying to educate
governments into seeing you know opening
their eyes and saying look you know in
Portugal can do this say for heroin
takers you America should do the same
thing they had a massive heroin epidemic
in the year 2000 and you know by
embracing those heroin addicts and
helping them become normal members of
society again they managed to solve the
problem America now has the biggest
heroin epidemic in history and and yet
the way they're dealing with it is the
same old old war on drugs and the way to
deal with it is you know you you ask
these people to come forward you
you help them with their vixy's
initially you've supplied them with a
product you stopped them having to break
an entry into people's homes and you
make sure that when they're ready to
wean themselves off that you helped them
win themselves off and you make the map
useful members of society again you know
I'm part of something called the global
drug Commission and we've got 15 people
will be used to be presidents of their
country kopi announced on it and we've
done a lot of studies on this subject
and know we believe that every single
drug should be regulated and taxed and a
warning should be very firmly put on
these drugs in the same way you have
warnings on cigarettes or warnings and
alcohol but that is the way to overcome
this problem not to carry on having
having a war on drugs I think this is
tremendously important and I'm really
glad that you brought it up just having
seen my best friend growing up I grew up
on in rural Long Island my best friend a
few years ago died of an opiate overdose
and it's it's a hugely important problem
that is not being it's being addressed
in the most counterproductive of ways as
you noted and I'm actually this is
probably something we could we could
talk for a long time about but involved
with supporting research at places like
Johns Hopkins looking at even using
certain things like safes psilocybin for
the treatment of certain forms of
addiction and end-of-life anxiety and so
on but the important component of that
or one of the components of that being
looking at how to reschedule and
properly supervise and regulate these
compounds as opposed to immediately
criminalizing them and just compounding
the problem with another hundred
problems that that end up fixing nothing
so I much appreciate you bringing that
up yeah well thank you I think
and I mean it's sad and strange that
year after year goes by and it's you
just if you talk together to people in
you know in in positions of power they
actually individually write
- did they just don't have the courage
to do it and and we just need a bit more
courage I think with some of our
politicians well Richard thank you so
much for being an agent of change and
also sharing your stories in such a way
that you inspire other people to do the
same and I'm really excited to see what
other dents you put in the world and for
people listening they can find you on
social media Richard Branson everywhere
certainly they should check out finding
my virginity and to people listening I
will link to everything including the
the new book and the show notes at tim
dot blog ford slash podcast and richard
you have so many projects and so many
things to keep you high on life so i
will let you get back to it but thank
you so much for taking the time to chat
today thanks so much Tim all right I'll
talk to you soon thanks hey guys this is
Tim again just a few more things before
you take off number one this is five
bullet Friday do you want to get a short
email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday that provides a little morsel of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com
I love WordPress I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com for
or everything every day my site Tim my
blog is built on it the websites for my
books political tools of titans tribe of
mentors it's all in wordpress.com and
the founder matt mullenweg when my close
friends has appeared on this show many
times
just search matt mullenweg tequila
Ferriss for quite an exciting time
whether you're looking to create a
personal blog a business site of both
you can make a really big impact right
out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com
and you'll be in good company it's used
by the New Yorker jay-z Beyonce 5:38
TechCrunch Ted CNN and time just to name
a handful and one of my friends at
Google she'll remain nameless has told
me that WordPress comm offers the quote
best out-of-the-box SEO imagine Allah
end quote it's one of the many reasons
that nearly 30 percent of the Internet
is run on WordPress you do not need
experience or to hire someone that's
perhaps the best part where crestcom
guide you through the entire experience
they have hundreds of designs and
templates that you can use and it's easy
to get started there's no need to worry
about security upgrades hosting any of
that therefore 24/7 support and they're
very very responsive if you have
questions they can write back to you and
this allows you to create the highest
quality with the least amount of
headache and friction so if you're
building a website period when my
friends come to me and ask what I use
what I recommend they use the answer is
WordPress calm so check it out if you
want to get started today learn more
with a 15% discount off any plan go to
wordpress.com forward slash Tim to
create your website and find the plan
that's right for you it's a little more
take a look wordpress.com 4/10 or 15%
off a brand new website check it out
this episode is brought to you by ascent
protein the cleanest least processed
protein I've ever consumed and I have
tried just about everything since well
before the 4-hour body I've started my
day with 20 to 30 grams of protein first
thing that has been part of my routine
but I don't always have the time or
necessarily the desire to cook
entire meal so what to do protein
powders can be a fast way to get this
protein need met but most products are
full of crap
they're bleached they've excess sugar
terrible artificial sweeteners or just
straightforward low-grade low quality
protein a scent contains zero artificial
ingredients and the parent company is
actually a cheese manufacturer so they
produce their own native proteins it's
it's really fascinating and I've looked
at their processing it takes or it took
them about five years to develop you can
mix the protein in as little as four
ounces without any clumps or issues of
mix ability whatsoever and they nailed
the taste they tested it for instance
with the chocolate version 282 different
versions that put a lot of money and a
lot of time into Rd for this particular
product and they have both way and
micellar casein so if you want to say
improve body composition and recovery
overnight slow release you can take the
micellar casein or in my case whey
protein I would take post-workout for
instance or in the morning so check it
out these guys are really fascinating
visit ascent protein dot-com forward
slash Tim that's a scen TPR otti n.com
ascent like first ascent going up ascent
protein component / Tim and you will
receive 20% off your entire purchase if
you want a very quick 20 or 30 gram dose
to start your day or after workout this
is a fantastic option it is arguably the
best that I've found so again check it
out
ascent protein comm forward slash Tim
[Applause]